Let's go next to Bobby from Arizona.
Hey, can you hear me?
Yes, I can. How are you, Bobby?
I'm well, this is really exciting
because I have recently discovered you. Oji
is like maybe six or so months before the
last election. So it's really exciting.
Is Bobby short for Roberta?
No, it's actually short just for just Bobby
Joe, but. Oh, OK. Very common question.
Thank you.
I'll be glad to clarify.
So my question was going to be in regards to
Arizona's recent shift to blue and young voters
voting more Democratic or more independent, I
know I've got a few people who don't necessarily
see that they're they're a Democrat, but they
they don't they're definitely not Republican. So
with the shift in blue, I know a lot of it from
what I've seen being in Arizona and obviously
I think has to do with Trump's, you know,
decision to be distancing or be rude to
John McCain's legend. He's really big out here.
Interesting. So locally, a lot of Republicans are
they really didn't like when when Trump
said stuff like, I prefer war heroes
who don't get captured and stuff like that.
There is actually a big sign the day after the
election where is Trump's face and John McCain's?
And it was like John McCain like came back from
heaven. Interesting. It's a big local thing out
here. And then the other part of it, I think,
is there's going to be more of a standing for
blue just because of the young voters. And I
was wondering if you had an opinion on young
voters turning blue because I had an argument
with someone. There's like no one just because
John McCain I'm my case. I don't think it is.
Oh, no. I think it's more bit. So there's there's
two different things. There's are there more young
people and the young people are just more on
the left, or are you saying that there are
young people voting in Arizona that used to vote
Republican now and now we're voting for Democrats.
So I know personally that's my case, the latter.
So I grew up with with boomer parents and they
were very Republican. And that's all I was
fed Republican rhetoric. So I had as soon as
I became older and started actually interacting
with people, I did end up learning more about the
world and mineralized. Let's not really not fair,
but not the right way I feel like should be done.
Yeah. So more independent media, more things
on YouTube of your show, I discovered and
I realized more and more about things that
I wanted versus what my parents wanted.
Right. I know personally that was my decision.
But I yeah. I mean, anecdotally, there's I know
of a lot of that going on. I know people who
voted for Joe Biden in Arizona who essentially
had never voted for a Democrat at the national
level since they became old enough to vote.
It's of course, anecdotal, but it's interesting
that you're observing that in Arizona, because
the I know lots of people who are on the left
and didn't vote and then they went out and voted
for Biden in order to remove Trump in November.
But those are people who were always on the left
in Arizona specifically. I know people that are
exactly what you're saying you yourself are, which
is they actually used to vote for Republicans and
then they voted for Joe Biden. So I don't know
what to make of it. These are just anecdotes, but
obviously it bodes well for the left in Arizona.
Yeah, no, I think those are going to be more
of a blue shift. I and I don't think it's
just like a one time thing personally.
Let's hope. Let's hope. And now how
are things going on masse wise? Are people because
I know that Arizona has been some describe it as a
covid hell scape. How is it going there right now?
It depends on the areas. Like if you go
to like north the like the richer areas,
it's much more relaxed and then more.
I think a lot of businesses are taking more
of the ownership on the requirement. Oh, so
it just really depends on the areas that you
go to. I think it's a lot of dependent on
whether or not you say anything. Like
I had gone to the store and I asked
those people without notice and I asked Associate,
I was like, hey, do something. And they did. But
it's one of those situations where it's just
it's going to take as a group, as a society,
if you like to put the pressure, because I
think more people will fold in that situation.
I think you're right. And I mean, listen,
hopefully we can vaccinate quickly enough
that this becomes a non-issue because some
people are just not going to wear masks.
Yeah, I'm looking forward to when I'm available.
I'm in the younger category and I'm I'm relatively
healthy. I'm staying more isolated. I work
from home. So I'm willing to wait until it's
available for my group than just rushing in. But
I do know that my husband works at and grocery
and they just open it up in Arizona for grocery
workers to get it. So I'm excited to have him.
Yeah, lots of states, even in advance of
May one are saying eighteen plus sixteen
plus can get vaccinated. So let's let's hope
so. All right. Thanks, Bobby, for the call.
I think you all
right, Bobby from Arizona, very, very good caller.